all right ralph i'll throw this one to
you to start here so you in particular
have reunited with so so many actors
from karate kid one two and three so of
the bunch who would you say change the
lease where the second you hit set with
them it was like they never skipped a
beat but then on the other hand whose
approach to the work has evolved the
most and you know made you really
shocked by what they were capable of now
well thanks for not pitting one actor
against the other and putting it all in
my lap but uh
they um
who wait wait
you want me to hand this off to you no
no that's your question i work with all
those guys so who
you know for the most part when i go
down the list from whether it's
elizabeth shu or tamlin or yuji or or
sean or
or uh thomas um it's everyone brings the
a game that get that's 100
and and that's
so inspiring to me it just raises my
game so you have someone like like yuji
who comes in and plays the flip side you
know i all the scenes i played with him
he was beating the crap out of me sort
of like all the scenes in karate kid i
played with johnny lawrence and billy
so it becomes this different thing you
know uh i guess i would have to say
that thomas
uh as terry silver and adding the layers
into his bond villainousness
villainousness
uh has been
um
beyond that above expectations of what i
expected i said that's the weirdest
sentence ever so fix it in post please
but but i think um
i gained such great richness out of out
of what eugene has brought to chosen and
and that with daniel russo in this
season but thomas has really taken a
character that was kind of
two-dimensional villainous in the
original in the in the karate kid part
three and and been one of the highlights
of the later seasons of this show so um
um and then what was the second half of
that question out of our time's up
someone who hasn't changed at all
someone where their approach to the work
has stayed so consistent that it was
like no time had passed between the
karate kid films and what they're doing
now
uh tamlin
uh as as kumiko and ug as well
yeah
all right billy so that's a tough
question that's a real novel
i've always come i'm always coming with
the tough questions
by now uh billy you can't be biased with
this question but i've watched so many
theory videos about this over the years
that i need to know your opinion johnny
versus mike barnes if they had met in an
all valley tournament back in the day
who would have won and also if they
fought today who do you think would beat
the other um
well listen
because this isn't going to get seen by
anybody right nobody nobody might give
my hand just the three of us you're
gonna have to put me in it like you have
to black me out and i'll be like
my editor can cover all of this
uh listen back in the day johnny
lawrence was a
nothing could have defeated johnny
lawrence back in the day except a crane
kick that was completely illegal mike
barnes was chained in his style johnny
lawrence was the king uh sorry daniel
uh and then today i mean listen
um i don't know i mean um
i'd like to see that i'd like to see
that match too uh sean's a good martial
artist in real life
so it would be a lot of fun to do i'm
gonna leave it for the fans to figure
out i can't chime in on that i mean i'm
biased to that so you know johnny
doesn't lose even if he loses so
um talk about vacuuming yourself out of
the room yeah yeah
so there you go so uh uh but uh yeah it
would be a great fight it would be a
great fight you know um i don't know
we'll see i'd be down to see that all
right this next one's for both of you
now so billy the last time we spoke you
mentioned that you guys film these
episodes super super fast where
sometimes you don't have the ideal
amount of time to prep before you shoot
something so in season five can each of
you pick a scene where you knew even
with the quick shooting schedule that it
was of the utmost importance to you to
carve out time to workshop or prep a
little bit more we do that we want time
all the time like but there just isn't i
mean the big fight in silver's mansion
literally was learning it on the spot
all that stuff on the spot like i'd
never seen
i saw it one time in a previz where they
shoot it one time but by the time we got
to shoot it it had completely been
redone so i literally were learning
every move on the go and sometimes it's
that way i have a great stunt guy who
knows it he works with the sun guys i
watch him we do you know five or six
moves and and we knock those i watch him
then i do it and then we
we dump those five and then we go the
next and we keep going on like that so
it's really on the fly i think the most
important thing is just to be stretched
out
um you know the prep time is great if
you can have it but it's always gonna
change when you get there ralph and i
had a fight in my apartment and we had
like it was another leg of that that we
rehearsed and we got there like yeah
okay let's chop it down so yeah you just
have to be stretched and ready and you
have to have had enough you know and we
do it in pieces you know we do it in
pieces it's like five or six moves
you know that's the only way to do it
when you don't have the rehearsal time
which we we don't yeah um even the
the fight the the terry silver showdown
at the end
um with me that was when we were at the
double up day point we're shooting two
different crews trying to finish out
before the deadline it's just crazy how
we pull it off and but on the flip side
of that the fight in episode five with
with thomas and myself we had the day to
do that scene and it was
it shows we had the time you know but
somehow uh with great music good editing
and and you care about the characters so
you're forgiving you know you're in
you're in the heads of these these uh
characters and that's why it works i
don't know how you guys do it every
single season i'm like this is so damn
good how can it get stronger and
stronger next time around and you just
add those layers that build these
characters above and beyond what i've
ever could have anticipated so thank you
yet again we care that's part of it too
yeah
you can see you could feel it on screen
when you're watching it
i could stay here all day they're going
to kick me out i'm leaving now but thank
you guys so much and i'll see you guys
thanks to everyone behind the scenes
thanks for the support always always
yeah and i bet on johnny lawrence
can i put that back in the uh the
interview i didn't stop rolling
do what you got to do perry
have a good one guys